i saw pictures you work being a mom you
you make these creative breakfasts
yes i do well there's a reason i
sometimes i share on my instagram
sometimes that i'm making the toddler
breakfast
it's basically because the toddler
doesn't eat i have a two and a half year
old who
i have no idea how he's alive um all he
eats is white bread
ketchup and milk and he basically i
like present these really cute little
things like i'll make toast and put a
face on it
and he's like now i don't like it
he's like a medieval kid
bring me milk and then he like drinks
his milk like this
why is he from serbia
i don't like it
but i saw these these pictures of these
things you're making look at that that's
adorable
doesn't that look different oh look at
this there's one coming up keep going i
think that's amazing
maybe that makes them afraid oh there's
a turtle yeah the sunglasses
if someone put that much thought into my
food i would have so much
joy in my life but i will i can relate
because
our kids when they were babies and to
this day it's to get them to eat
anything green
you have to like hide it in a chocolate
bar you know
it's ridiculous my other kids eat really
well and this one just came out of
nowhere and eats nothing
yeah it's those serbian babies
i eat none of it i don't know about the
white bread with ketchup